MARTIN GANNHOLM: Good
afternoon, and thank you
for joining our session.
My name is Martin Gannholm.
And during the six years
that I've been at Google,
I've worked on and
led the teams that
have delivered a number
of the cloud products
you might be using, like
Compute Engine, Container
Engine, and Kubernetes.
LOUIS RYAN: Hi, I'm Louis Ryan.
I've been at Google
about nine years now.
I've worked on
Google's API platforms.
So when you make API calls
to Google, all of those
go through stuff that
my team works on.
And also more recently, I've
been doing a lot of work
on gRPC.
But I'm going to hand
you back to Martin
who's going to show you
some interesting stuff.
MARTIN GANNHOLM:
So what we're going
to talk to you about is based
on a lot of our experiences
building and running large-scale
cloud services at Google
and how we can bring this
kind of learning to Kubernetes
and you folks.
So there's been a lot of
talk over the last few years
about zero ops and
server-less computing
and how these concepts allow
you to spend less of your time
managing and dealing
with infrastructure.
In effect, they can let you
run ambitious apps at scale
without having to
know all the details.
So if you use Google
App Engine or BigQuery,
you're familiar
with how they allow
you to focus on your expertise
and writing your business logic
or your data processing, and
not managing all the machines
underneath the covers.
So that's kind of the context.
So we're going to talk to you
about some technologies that
are currently under
development in open source,
and that will get you
on the way to being
able to operate
systems at scale,
cheaply, efficiently,
and securely.
So we consider these
building blocks
the beginning of a journey to
deliver the promise of zero ops
and server-less computing in
the integrated hybrid cloud.
So all the different parts
of your solution stacks,
whether they're
running in-house,
on-prem, or if they're in
a public or private cloud,
whether you wrote the components
or whether you acquired them
from some third party, we will
cover all of those pieces.
So there are three
intertwined principles
that we believe are
the foundation that
will get us there.
The first is services,
not infrastructure.
And what we mean
by that is we need
to look at it at a
service abstraction layer.
And if we do that,
we can get away
from dealing with
the infrastructure.
It's very common for
companies in recent years
to have a service
catalog that make
it easier for their
application developers
to sort of get bootstrapped
with different pieces.
But oftentimes those are just
a piece of infrastructure,
like a virtual machine that gets
provisioned, some deployment
system or scripts run and
install things on them.
And at that point, it's yours.
It's very much like
getting a free puppy.
And you quickly learn
that getting the puppy
was the easy part.
You've now got to
take care of it.
In contrast, often managed
capabilities behind an API
is the kind of thing
that is allowed
for the explosive adoption
of cloud services.
And we like to
bring that same kind
of thinking to all the different
components that you build
or that you acquire
from other people.
So choosing an abstraction
layer and getting it right
means a few things.
You'll be able to separate the
construction, the operation,
and the usage of components
from each other, which gives you
more flexibility in how
you source the components
and how you manage them.
You'll be able to inject key
behaviors in different control
points in this higher
level system, allowing
for many of the
intent-based functions that
will let you operate at scale
with little or no effort.
You'll also be able to
compose your solutions
across a wide range of
infrastructures of environments
and technologies.
And this really brings us
to the next principle--
interoperability.
This is fundamentally about
choice and flexibility,
about giving you
a path from today
to tomorrow and to whatever
the future may bring.
This includes legacy components
that you already have running
that you use, in-house developed
services that might be more
modern, third-party
software-as-a-service pieces.
And all of these will
span multiple different
environments.
And it's all about allowing
you to choose the best
option for each individual
piece without giving up
on the promise of zero
ops and server-less.
And this is a vision that
is only realizable if we
succeed in the third pillar.
We like automation at Google.
We think that teaching
computers to execute
repetitive, error-prone
and large-scale tasks so
that humans can focus
on value-added pursuits
is a good thing.
So for example, if you want to
apply an enterprise-wide policy
to all of your services,
that should be trivial.
Do you want to
canary test an update
and then roll that out to
all of your zones or whatever
geographical spread
that you have
if no anomalies are detected
and do that automatically?
Yep, that's one of the
things you want to do.
What if something wasn't right?
Automatic rollback.
So the answer for us
is automate everything.
So let's touch on two of the
hard problems to solve for.
Let's just say it--
networking's hard.
Doing networking
right is harder.
And now you want
it to be secure?
You've got to be kidding.
Nobody wants to deal
that, at least I don't.
So we talk about
this as the space
between the micro-services.
So the red lines here
represent that space.
And so the questions are--
how do you securely
connect services together?
Can you do encrypted and
authenticated access?
Can you protect against DDoS or
even just unintentional packet
storms?
Credentials-- that
would be great
if you could flow credentials
through the system.
But not just once, you
want key rotation, right?
You want these things to
update and manage that.
So those are the
kinds of things that
would be better if you
didn't have to deal with.
The second part is hybrid
cloud or multi-cloud.
That can be hard.
If you use a homogeneous
system, like Kubernetes,
for example, which
is multi-platform,
you can run it in
many different places.
And if you're all in on
that, everything's fine.
But most people don't
have that luxury.
So you have legacy.
You have virtual machines.
Those are the kinds
of things that you
have to sort of
include as you evolve.
So some of the
questions you might
have is, well, if I'm
using a service on-prem,
is that different?
Do I have to
operate differently?
Do I have to deal
with it differently
than a third-party
acquired service?
How do I tell which
services I'm actually
dependent on across
my entire solution?
How do I enforce company
policies across those?
Or can only do it on
a subset that I have
under my immediate control?
And how do I get a handle on the
security aspect of this layout?
So let's get more
concrete and talk
about the service abstraction.
So we have partnered with
several other companies
around the Open
Service Broker API,
which is a relatively new
standard in the making which
originally came
from Cloud Foundry.
So those of you familiar
with Cloud Foundry
will recognize these concepts.
And so we're working
with these companies
on adopting and then extending
this great abstraction.
And so the importance
of a standard
is that services that are
written for consumption
in the Cloud Foundry
application will
be able to be used
unmodified from Kubernetes
with what we're going to show
you today and vice versa.
And so as people adapt their
services to this model,
the amount of places
you'll be able to use them
is going to be great.
So let's pretend that I
am a service producer.
And I want to package up
Google's cloud services
behind a broker
or inside a broker
so that people can
easily consume them.
So we want to expose
our cloud platform APIs,
like you see them down
there, Cloud Storage, PubSub,
BigQuery.
And so a broker can
have multiple services
that it's able to be a
factory for, essentially.
So let's look at one
of these, Cloud SQL.
So Cloud SQL has two
types of instances.
If you look on the
Cloud console it
has a first gen and
a second generation.
The Broker API has
a notion of a plan.
Each service class can
have one or more plans.
And so as a producer
I might choose
to use Gen 1 versus Gen 2 as the
two plans that I can offer you.
So when you want to
get one of these,
you choose which plan you want.
And I can make that
bifurcation there.
Alternately, I could choose
a different way to factor it.
I could say, well,
what if there are
different fundamental sizes--
small, medium, large?
I could do that.
That's another thing you
can do with the plan.
Or a different type of
a way to look at it is--
what about standard versus
high availability deployments
of Cloud SQL?
So those are different choices
that as a service producer
I have a lot of flexibility
with this API to specify.
So when you go and create
a service instance--
so you have a service class
you want an instance of.
You want to use it.
So you create a
service instance.
You also specify
which plan you want.
And so here are some
screenshots from Cloud SQL.
And you see on the left
are the options for Gen 1.
And on the right there's
a long scrollable list
of options on Gen 2.
And so the Service Broker
API allows for the difference
between these two things.
And in the future,
the parameters
that are valid for one
plan versus another
will be schematized and so
that we can then automate.
We can actually have the user
interface parse through that
and present you the
options really nicely
and be able to show
you what options
are valid for which plan.
So once you've created
a logical instance,
you want to use that
service from an application.
And rather than copying API
keys, IP addresses, configuring
SSL, and all those
kinds of things
that you today do in the in the
Cloud console, and then take
whatever information they give
you and apply those somehow
to your code, to your
config of your applications,
the Broker API, in conjunction
with another piece,
the service controller, which
I'll get to in a second,
has a way of configuring
and passing this information
directly into your application,
saving you that step.
So to illustrate this further,
the service controller
is a logical construct.
And it's tied to your
runtime environment.
So here you can see
the dotted box is meant
to be a Kubernetes cluster.
And so inside of that there's
a service controller that
understands what it's
like, what it means
to be a Kubernetes application.
So it sort of does some of
the work in this scenario.
So the service catalog
has a few purposes.
One, you can register brokers
with it, as many as you want.
What it does is it asks
the brokers what are
the available service classes?
And then it sort of creates
an aggregated catalog
of those things.
Additionally, the service
controller can let you--
and this functionality
doesn't exist today,
but this is one of
the things that we're
looking at is that this is
now a control point where
you can apply IAM policies.
So that you can say,
well, certain people
can't access the user service.
I can sort of lock
that down so they
can't bind to instances of
it, or they might not be
able to create instances of it.
So once the user
decides which service
they want to use, for example
lets pick Cloud PubSub,
they ask the
controller to create
an instance of the class.
And the controller delegates
to the broker and says,
hey, why don't you
create this class--
create an instance from it.
And then that, in turn, goes
and does whatever it does,
completely opaque.
You have no idea what it does.
It could provision
a large amount
of virtual infrastructure, many
virtual machines or whatever.
Or it could simply
just insert a row
in a database noting that you
now have a virtual instance.
So it's a nice abstraction
because it allows the service
provider to do whatever
implementation they
want, and it's transparent.
So, let's see, so now
we have the service,
and now we want to bind
an application to it.
We want to use it
from an application.
So here's an application,
just a Node.js application,
not a Kubernetes cluster.
And we want to tell
the system that we
want to bind these together.
So we talk to the service
controller, create a binding.
The service controller, once
again, delegates to the broker.
The broker figures out
what are the coordinates,
where is the actual instance,
what IP address, which port,
those kinds of things.
And again, it's
service-dependent,
but that's a very common type
of thing that it returns.
And it also returns
credentials, credentials
that could be unique
for each binding
or could be shared
for all the bindings
to a particular instance.
Again, this is a service--
it's part of the
service definition.
So as a service producer,
you can choose what
makes sense in your scenario.
And the last step that the
service controller does
is that it sort of creates
the virtual binding
and injects those
credentials and those
coordinates into the application
so they can very easily consume
it.
And I'll show this in the
demo in a few minutes.
So, yeah, in Kubernetes this is
done through secrets and config
maps, and the application
just accesses them
through environment variables.
So here are the pieces we're
going to talk to today.
So these are three different
open source things.
I talked about the
service broker.
I hinted at the service catalog.
That's what I call the
service controller.
So a service catalog is
a special interest group
that's part of Kubernetes.
And so we're doing work there
in the Kubernetes community
to add that capability
to Kubernetes.
And service mesh is
something that Louis
will get into depth on, and
it's another open source project
that we're engaged in.
It's actually called Istio.
But we'll get to the
URLs for that later.
So what these do-- we talked
about what the broker does.
It's a core service abstraction.
And the catalog
basically provides
environment-specific
help to sort of get
consumption of services
to be something
that is very natural
in an environment,
in this case, Kubernetes.
And the mesh is for
traffic management
and inter-service
policy controls.
So this is the application
we will show you in the demo.
What we have here,
the gray boxes,
are existing micro-services
in my deployment.
And so what we're going
to do-- the application--
the purpose is to have a
bookstore to sell some books.
So we want to have a front-end
that shows you the books
and allows you to buy them.
It's a very, very,
very simple app.
And I suppose we were
already selling other items--
sneakers or something
else-- and that's
why we already have these
inventory and payments
connections.
So we will add the books
front-end application.
We'll bind it to the
existing micro-services.
And then we'll all get
to PubSub in a second.
So can we please switch
to the demo machine?
It went to sleep.
So here's the
Kubernetes dashboard.
And we have a few new things on
the left here, a little service
catalog.
And here we can see the
service classes that
are available for creation.
If we look here, there's
a couple of catalogs.
There's a KA Desk 1, which is
really our department catalog.
These are the micro-services
that we built in-house,
and we've put them in a
broker, in a catalog there.
But we don't need to
create any of these
because we already have
some pre-created instances
for the purposes of this demo.
So what I'm going to do is
I'm going to switch over to--
I'm going to run a script
to install the application.
So this is really just creating
a deployment in Kubernetes
using YAML file.
But I've just wrapped
it up in a shell script.
And so that will do some work.
There we go.
We have created something.
And so if I say, kube
control get pods,
we will be able to see--
there we go, booksfe.
So this is my new
deployment here.
These are some pods,
and we have an error.
Shucks.
What is that?
Let's take a look.
OK.
Deployments, here we go--
red text.
So it says, secrets
booksfe users not found.
OK.
So why is this?
Well, it turns out there's
good reason for this.
So here's a little bit
of the source code of--
whoops, that's not
what I meant to do.
This is a little bit
of the source code
of that front-end application.
And some of the stuff
that it does here
is it tries to access some
things in the environment.
And these actually
come from secrets.
And so the secret
doesn't exist because we
haven't created the binding.
So one of the
things that happens
is when you create a binding,
under the covers the service
controller, because
it's Kubernetes, says,
well, I'm going to propagate
these things in a secret.
And then the application
is configured
to expect that secret to exist.
And those environment
variables get created
from values in the secrets.
And so Kubernetes will
just not launch these pods
if all the dependencies
haven't been satisfied.
So we will go back and
just create some bindings.
So we're going to go in here.
And for each one of
these, for most of them--
what I'm typing here is--
this is a label.
So in Kubernetes,
everything is done--
specifying what
you want to address
is all done through labels.
So our label for our
application is booksfe.
And I have to do
this three times.
So we're going to copy that.
So that's inventory.
Whoops, that's the one I did.
We don't need to do payments.
We'll do purchases.
And then we will do the
last one, which is users.
And what I didn't show you, if I
did a kube control get secrets,
you'll see that it has a
bunch of them now that are--
it has a couple that
are a few seconds old--
booksfe, inventory,
purchases, and now there's
one called user.
So that one just got created.
So now those secrets exist.
And let's see what's going
on with our deployment.
So now when we go back,
we'll see that the deployment
is actually now running.
So Kubernetes just
figured that out,
that now those
dependencies are satisfied.
So we have a front-end.
And so now I am going
to launch my app.
I'm going to launch the new
web browser for this app.
Oh, yes, it works.
So here is my front-end.
I have some books it's
getting from the inventory,
and I am just going
to buy one of these.
This is a classic book.
And let's buy this
"Crockpot Recipes."
And I can look at my
purchases and see that I have
a couple of things right there.
So let me show you one thing.
I am going to show
you the secrets,
just so you can see
how those work--
secrets.
And then I'm going
to say kube control.
I'm going to describe that.
I'm going to look inside of it.
And I'm going to
pick one of these.
Whoops.
Oh, describe secret.
That was-- oh, of course.
I'm just going to do this.
I'm going to cheat.
There we go.
I forgot the O YAML.
So here you can see
some of the data.
So the host name and
port are being passed in.
And that came from the binding.
So those originally
came from the service,
and the controller injected
those into the application
through secrets and
environment variables.
So now we're going to
make a modification.
So say that we're selling books.
Our publishers are very
interested in-- well, let
us know when you
sell some books.
Cloud PubSub might
be a good way.
If you publish
events, they can just
subscribe to those channels
and then look at them.
So in order to do
that, what I want to do
is I want to go back
to the service catalog.
And I don't have Cloud PubSub.
So I'm going to add one.
I'm going to do it up here--
add catalog.
So I'm going to
create one called GCP.
Bear with me while
I type incorrectly.
And then I will use this.
AUDIENCE: You forgot a T.
MARTIN GANNHOLM: I
missed something?
Oh, yeah, look at that.
Thank you.
All right, double check.
It's the first time I've screwed
that up on all my demo runs.
I've made other mistakes
but not that one.
Ah, look at that,
a thing of beauty.
So now we have four services
that our environment knows
about that we can now create.
So let's just spend
no further time.
Let's create an instance.
Let's create the
PubSub instance.
Now, the interesting thing
that I will show you here
is that when we create
a binding to it--
so we're going to bind to
it from our application.
And we still want it to
use the same application.
And I'm going to now
type some parameters.
Remember earlier when I said
that we will have schematized
the parameters in the future?
Well, that's the future.
So right now I've got to
type in some ugly JSON.
So it's a very small
amount of text.
So this is just setting
the permissions on that.
Does that look right?
I think it does.
So we'll create that binding.
So now I've said I want to
bind my application to that.
But the application doesn't
know how to talk to PubSub yet.
And so for purposes of
making this a shorter demo,
I'm not going to make
changes to the code
and recompile it and
rebuild my Docker image
and everything like that.
What I've done-- or actually
what one of my engineers did
was--
basically make it optional
so that we actually
can-- we have the same code.
And it just knows it's passed a
parameter that says whether it
should use PubSub or not.
So here is the code for that.
And so I just need to make
a change to the YAML file.
That is one of our config files.
Save that.
Now, if I can update
this application,
we should be able to see some
action on that deployment
again.
All right, so kube
control get pods.
Take a look at what's in here.
Yep, you see one is terminating,
another one is running.
So it looks like we're
up in business again.
Where did I leave that window?
Demo-- nope.
What am I doing?
Oh, that is surprising.
Oh, there we go.
All right, so let's buy
a couple more books.
Let's buy this one.
And now let's go back here
and run a gcloud command.
So I'm to call gcloud
to basically fetch
from the subscription channel.
It's called GCP Next.
And ideally, everything works
and we get something back.
There we go.
OK, so there's the
purchase that was made.
Let's see if we
have another one.
Different message ID.
Not very exciting.
Let's see what else we got.
That was it.
I made two purchases.
So that's that piece.
And I'm just going to--
so now I'm going to hand off--
no.
I need to go back
to slides, please.
Can we show the
slides on the screen?
So what are some of
the key takeaways?
This is the app
that we modified,
and we showed how we
can easily connect
to preexisting services
from a new app and also
how to provision and
connect to a cloud
service in the same way.
One of the existing services,
the payment service here, we
didn't actually deal with that.
But what's interesting
is that it's actually
exposed as a service as well.
And so there's a way that
you can wrap existing legacy
things as services.
And those of you familiar
with Cloud Foundry
will recognize that
same capability.
And so a lot of the
benefits that you're
going to see, especially in
Louie's part of the talk,
are then applicable to
something like a legacy service,
like payments as well,
because it now gets
wrapped in this abstraction.
We also showed how we
need to know knowledge
of where the service
came from or how
to negotiate credentials.
The necessary information
just showed up
in secrets and then
environment variables.
Now let me hand off to
Louis, who will show you
some even cooler stuff.
LOUIS RYAN: Thank you, Martin.
Martin talked to
you a lot about how
people are going to
acquire services, how we're
going to make sure that services
have well-known relationships
with each other.
And now I'm going to show
you some of the things
that we'd like to
do underneath all
of that to help make
that work better
and to help you get some insight
into how those services are
talking to each other and be
able to start imposing policies
on the conversations that
those services are having
with each other.
And there's a term
floating around nowadays
that I think is gaining
some momentum for all of us,
and it's the service mesh.
You have lots of these services.
They're all talking
to each other.
It's not a network in the
traditional packet sense.
It's a network of services
and their relationships
with each other and all the
things that they want to do.
So I think of a service mesh
as a network for services.
So let's talk about
that a little bit.
I got the wrong button.
So what would you want a network
of services to do for you?
Well, when we build services
today, we want reliability.
We want them to perform well.
We want them to be able to deal
with transient failure modes.
Maybe if I bring up
a service and it's
talking to some other service,
and that service has a failure
mode, maybe I can't reach it
or maybe or one of the jobs
goes down.
I'd like the network,
the service mesh,
to take care of that for me.
We'd also like the service mesh
to help us with performance.
When I bring up lots
of jobs, and maybe I'm
bringing up stateful
jobs and stateless jobs
and doing all these types
of things in production,
routing traffic to a stateful
job when it hasn't had time
to warm up its cache is
probably a really bad thing
to do for latency.
And it might even be
a really bad thing
to do for availability
if cache loading is
a very expensive
operation, and you
start to get these
cascading failure modes.
We also want the network,
the service mesh,
to help us with visibility.
I'd like to know which services
are talking to each other.
I'd like to know if there
are services in my deployment
that I don't expect to be there.
So we'd like to have a lot
more visibility about what
the behavior is in this network.
And I'd like to
have control, right?
When a service is talking
to another service,
it would be very nice if I could
go and interpose in that flow
and say, no, you're not allowed
to make this communication.
You're violating some
corporate policy,
or you're using too
much of a resource
or doing these types of things.
So how do we make
all of that happen?
Can we switch back to the demo?
So meanwhile in ops land--
so while Martin was doing
all these wonderful things,
one of the things we also
spun up on the background
is some monitoring.
So all the services are
talking to each other.
They're generating traffic.
Wait a minute.
Did we switch to the demo?
Thank you.
So here's a typical
Grafana dashboard.
It's showing you the traffic
between the services.
We're showing you a simple
request-per-second metric.
And you can see that
we've annotated the graph
with the services, right?
So you know that
the bookfe service
is talking to purchasers
is talking to users.
And for some really
strange reason,
it's doing 60 QPS
of traffic, Martin?
This is the apps' guys running
load test in production again.
Well, let's go stop
that, because that's just
bad practice.
And that looked like it
was the books front-end.
Let's see-- books front-end
talking to the user service.
And Martin definitely did
not buy 50 books a second.
So let's go deal with that.
So we go back to our instances.
And we can go look
at the user service.
And we see we have our
binding-- books front-end
talking to the user service.
So let's dig in there.
And notice this link,
adds network function.
So this is very rough.
This is very much demo alpha
quality stuff at this point.
But if I go in here and
say add network function,
I can start to take some
action on the interaction
between those two services.
And in this case, I'm
going to impose a quota.
And I don't think Martin
really wants to buy
more than five bucks a second--
five books a second.
So I'm going to turn that on.
Now, what happened
under the hood,
the system is aware
of this binding.
It's going to take that
notion of relationship,
and it's going to push
a piece of configuration
down into a system and
say, hey, for this binding,
this relationship between two
surfaces, we want this quota.
So let's hop back on over
to the Grafana dashboard
and see if anything happened.
And look at that.
We see the error rate
start to spike up, right?
The book's front-end
services, or this load test
that Martin is running,
is still sending traffic.
But now we're rejecting it.
It's getting dropped.
And actually, it's not even
going into the service itself.
It's being dropped
earlier in the network.
And so we're seeing the
request will actually
start to cap out at 5
QPS, the valid ones.
And all the other traffic
is going to get rejected.
There are lots of
these types of things
that we can do in
this network if we
had this amount of
information if we're
able to interpose in the
traffic in sensible ways.
So how do we do
this type of thing?
And can we switch back
to the slides, please?
Although, Grafana's very pretty.
We could look at it for another
few minutes if you'd like.
Can we go back to the slides?
Thank you.
So how do we do this?
Well, the first thing
that we need to do
is we need to capture traffic.
We can't really do
anything if we don't
know what's moving around.
So here's a little subset
of the application.
We have the books app,
and we have users service.
And the books app is calling
the user service via its API.
Well, one of the things that
we did before Martin started
driving the demo is we installed
a component into the Kubernetes
cluster.
This is part of the
Istio project, which
Martin alluded to earlier.
And it's called
the proxy manager.
And what the proxy
manager does is
it listens to the
Kubernetes API.
And when you spin up pods, it
rewrites the pods on the fly
and injects proxies into them.
And then it also rewrites
the networking rules
inside Kubernetes.
So instead of that
traffic going directly
from the books front-end
to the users service,
it's actually going
through proxies.
And it's going through
a proxy on each side.
And we'll talk a
little bit about why
we do those types of things.
So now that we're
capturing traffic,
we can start to do
interesting things with it.
We could start to inject
network functions.
There's different classes
of network functions.
But we'll talk a little bit
about some of them here.
Maybe we want to roll out
a new version of the user
service, user service v2.
If you don't want to send
all of the production traffic
to it live, right?
Maybe you just want to
send 1% of the traffic.
So you want to qualify
that service in production
and make sure that it's stable
before you cut everything over.
The proxy that was injected
into the books at V
can now start to split the
traffic on your behalf.
And you can do this
at the operator level.
You don't have to go and
change the application code
to do this.
This is a very important thing.
Maybe the user
service is unreliable.
And so instead of the books app
having to deal with the fact
that its calls to the book
user service are flaky,
the proxy can actually
do the retries on behalf
of the service itself.
And so as long as the
proxy has some awareness
of what type of operation
it is-- is it item potent?
Is it safe to retry?
It can actually do these
things on your behalf.
And so if you have
a system where
you have this kind of
intermittent flakiness,
but it's not due to anything
that you can directly
control right now,
as an operator,
it's very often the
best of bad choices
is to start turning on retries
of exponential back-off.
Maybe you want to move the
service up into the cloud.
Maybe the user service is
this vast, enormous thing,
with hundreds of nodes in
seven different regions.
And now you want the proxy to
do smart intelligent things
on your behalf, like
load balancing, right?
Maybe that load balancing is
going to be regionally aware.
Maybe you might want
that load balancing
to do something like
optimize for latency, right?
So you're going to send
all of your traffic
to the most local node possible
until it starts to fill up,
and then you'll start to shard
it over to some other region.
Maybe you want to
maximize for availability,
and you just kind of keep an
eye on the back-end health
of each service, and the proxy
can be aware of these things.
Now, it's worth
noting that we didn't
have to rewrite any
application code to do this.
As Martin mentioned
earlier, the books front-end
was written in Node.js.
And user service, maybe
it's written in Go.
And the purchasing service is
written in .NET and all these
things.
So you have this big,
complex, polyglot environment.
Implementing sophisticated
network functions like these
is pretty expensive.
It actually takes a lot
of engineering effort
to get it right and
to do it consistently.
And consistency is what
really matters here, right?
If one piece of this network
doesn't really play well,
you can start to have
nasty things happen.
You can have cascading
failure modes.
And so having the proxy do
this work on your behalf
is actually massively
beneficial, right?
As long as it is consistent
and it does them well,
you don't have to worry about
the application developers
consuming some fancy
network run time,
trying to write
exponential back-off code
for the 15th time.
You just don't want to
be doing those things.
So what else can we do?
Well, we can inject identity.
So another piece that is still
installed into the Kubernetes
cluster is a
certificate authority.
And when we bring
the proxies up,
we also inject
credentials into them.
Those credentials, in
the case of Kubernetes,
are tied to Kubernetes
service accounts.
Now the proxies can
use those credentials,
those certificates, to enable
crypto between the proxies.
So we can do mutual TLS.
So now both applications,
both nodes of this graph,
can strongly verify
who's calling them.
They know it precisely.
And it's not just
some random piece
of code running in my cluster.
No, it's something running
with that authority.
Even if the user's
application isn't
written using some
standard protocol,
maybe it's not using HTP, right?
Maybe it's a database with
its own proprietary binary
protocol.
So maybe you can't
tunnel the identity
all the way down into it,
because it's protocol doesn't
matter or it won't
let you do that.
But at least you know the
traffic between those two nodes
is secure and is tied
to that identity.
And if it's tied
to that identity,
we can start to do
some things with it.
We can start injecting
policy associated with it.
Maybe the books application is
owned by Martin's development
group.
And maybe the user service
is owned by my group.
And I think his development
team is a bunch of cowboys,
and I'm just going to
shut them off, right?
I can do those types of things.
There's lots of interesting
things we can do with policy.
So another component that gets
injected into the Kubernetes
environment is this
thing we call the mixer.
And it can do a wide
range of things.
So I showed you earlier--
we showed you monitoring, right?
We inject this component,
and the proxy's
sending all this
information to it
about the behavior
of the network.
And we simply flow that
into Grafana, right?
We flow it through
Prometheas into Grafana,
and we had some nice dashboards
and things like that.
And I can visualize my
network and the behavior
of the services between them.
And we could have done
that with Stackdriver
or some other monitoring tool.
We also did quota, right?
And in the example
that I showed you
we have a quota component
running inside this.
And on the user side
it said, hey, I'm
supposed to enforce
5 DPS of quota,
and it just prevented the calls
on that server-side proxy.
It prevented them from actually
getting into the user service.
And if there was
mutual trust, then we
could have actually done
that check all the way back
up at the book side, and
the traffic would never
even hit the physical network.
But in worlds where you span
multiple trust boundaries,
you really do need
to make sure that you
enforce ACL-like checks
in the same trust
domain as the service.
We could also have done
authentication in ACL-ing.
So maybe you have multiple
authentication schemes
in your network.
Maybe you're using the
OAuth for [? signjots ?]
or who knows what.
And those credentials
are flowing through,
let's say, HTP calls.
You can delegate them
out to the service,
and they can make sure
that they're consistently
enforced across the network.
And also you can enforce
ACL policies, right?
If I have that
notion of identity,
whether it's a
mutual TLS identity,
maybe it's the Kubernetes
service account, maybe
it's something else, it
doesn't really matter.
You can use that to
perform ACL-ing checks.
And a lot of companies out
there have standard ACL policy
systems.
And you can use this
to integrate that.
And this is probably
the most important point
is that the system
is easy to customize.
And so what we've really
done is set up a framework
where we provide a whole
bunch of standard signals
about the traffic
flowing between services.
And then we provide this
convenient runtime integration
point, where you can go and
put control over that traffic.
So it will know which
service it came from,
which service it's going
to, what the operation is,
what region it came from, what
credential or identity does
that have, how big is the thing.
You can enforce whatever
policy you want.
And so this mixer thing,
the current implementation
is written in Go.
We think Go is a good language
for people to write extensions
in and to plug them
into this framework
and then just deploy
into the cluster.
So in conclusion, we
have our principles.
And Martin talked a lot
about these in the beginning.
And the big one being services
not infrastructure, right?
What we're trying to focus
on is services as units
that you can find,
acquire, consume,
and then operate, right?
And not the lower-level building
blocks necessary to do all
those types of things--
bringing the level
of extraction up.
We talked about
interoperability.
And in particular with the
open service broker API--
it's a community effort.
And we showed you a
way to bring services
from other environments
into your workplace, right?
I had my own catalog.
I could take Google's catalog.
I could take some
other vendor's catalog,
bring them in, and start
to work with those things.
Or maybe as an
internal thing, right,
I just create my own
catalog and I curate it.
And that's all that my internal
developers are allowed to use.
And there's this
qualification process
to get things into the catalog.
And then we talked
about automation.
We want to make sure that
everything is automatable.
So we walked you through
our UI, and we showed you
a bunch of command line
stuff, and I did some things
to enforce policy.
And then I showed you
some of how that worked.
But everything here
is driven by an API.
So if you want to change the
policies around how services
talk to each other, you make
API calls to do that, right?
You probably need to have a
lot of privilege to do it,
but that's what you
should be doing.
And so you can start to automate
the rollout of services,
automate the acquisition of
services from third parties,
and do all these
types of things.
This is entirely open.
This is a collaborative effort.
Google is not doing this on
its own or anything like it.
And so Martin talked about
the open service broker.
He also talked about the
Kubernetes service catalog.
And I talked a little bit about
the service mesh and Istio.
And these are the
companies that we're
working with on a daily basis
to make that stuff happen.
So here's some
useful links, right?
You can go and follow these
links, read about this stuff.
As Martin warned you
at the beginning,
things are alpha, sharp,
pointy, dangerous,
borderline unreadable.
Maybe you have to read the code
to figure out how it works.
It could be quite painful.
So hopefully the next
time we give this talk,
there'll be nice shiny docs
when you go follow these links,
and everything will be
entirely understandable.
And you'd all be using
it, and you wouldn't
need to ask me any questions.
[MUSIC PLAYING]